[Music]
the extra-large is available in cayenne
moss and aubergine and the plum black I
really want plum do you think Moss is
pretty you know I don't know lady why
don't you just pick a color please Steve
Johnson he never struck me as the kind
of guy you'd go get small Wow so the
decision to downsize thing takes
pressure right off especially money
pressure you look like Kate move time to
know we're really strapped you want my
advice
Lee's your lands where you want to be in
leisure Lane your hundred thousand
dollars translate to twelve million
dollars Wow I just got another diamond
bracelet pretty nifty huh okay go for it
nervous little today you will undergo
the permanent and irreversible procedure
known as downsizing
granny you've got a call Paul don't be
mad at me please don't be mad I can't
leave my family I can't leave my friends
I'm sorry Paul I should have been
thinking about myself thinking about
yourself
hi-five you just all as large as you can
please
I noticed we put a pretty big dent
anyone's self-esteem but downsizing is
about hitting the reset button start all
over world is filled with things to see
that Willie's really sick
you'll help hook
these are the people that we should be
helping
[Music]
something Betty beeps something
top-secret why did I downsize so that I
could be here right now I finally have a
chance to do something that matters
[Music]
we're in the normal world and then
something happens oh my god you realize
we're not
[Music]
you